i'm greg jarbo and i'm the content
marketing faculty chair at market motive
and what is that i mean what we're going
to talk about in this first module
of a content marketing foundation course
is liberally content marketing um
okay what is it
so content marketing is not a new
concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the michelin brothers in france
and the michelin brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know a little refresher
right now
were two brothers who made pneumatic
tires
and they were trying to sell them along
with an innovative product at its time
called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place france
where frankly people didn't like to get
outside of paris and into the provinces
because my god what was worth going out
there for
you know
for paris it's all happening here
and what the michelin brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
and use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content marketing in my book
was the michelin guide
and the michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed
restaurants
not just restaurants nearby in paris but
restaurants out there
in the provinces
and the michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant i know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to die for the ratatouille ah you
you got to have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way now since we're going
to give you a guide
and you have to get out of paris in
order to get there we're going to tell
you where you can find gasoline along
the way
which hotels you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the way just in case
you have to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a michelin tire because it's a
pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or
tire repair i mean that was in there but
it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to their audience about what
their audience was truly passionate
about which in
paris in 1900
was food
and by creating content
that got the audience to get into their
new innovative automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three-star restaurant
people got more flats
people had to replace their tires
but it was worth it
and oh by the way
michelin sold more tires
so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of
you know hit a pause and like well we're
doing content marketing we need to come
up with a concept
think back to the michelin guide it's
it's great foundation
so let's go
to a modern definition where are we now
in the 21st century
when it comes to content marketing
well you can read the slide here and
read the definition and some people like
reading definitions i'm not going to
read it to you but i am going to
highlight a couple of words in the
definition that i think are absolutely
critical to any definition
of content marketing
the content that you create needs to be
relevant
and it also has to be
valuable
now if it's not relevant
then you're not actually meeting my
needs or interests
you know and why would i be interested
and we've gotten way too tired
of screening out the commercial that
comes on
um you know trying to sell us snow tires
and pardon me we live in florida
i don't use snow tires what the what the
heck is this commercial doing
you know interrupting what i'm watching
so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out
and the valuable the valuable can can
work in a lot of different ways it can
be interesting
it can be useful
you know value
is an interesting proposition all by
itself
but that's the key to content marketing
uh it's not just creating more spam
it's not just throwing more trash over
the fence and hoping something happens
this is something where if you've
created valuable and relevant content
you know what your customers will find
you
that's a whole different kind of
proposition